authorities in hong kong are imposing
their toughest restrictions since the
start of the pandemic as infection
numbers explode most venues including
schools gyms churches and hair salons
must close cover 19 cases have almost
doubled to hit a new record high
hundreds queue to get tested as hong
kong prepares for some of its toughest
covert restrictions yet
as many countries shift their approach
to living with the virus
hong kong is pursuing a zero-covered
strategy in line with the chinese
mainland
but a sudden surge in cases is
complicating matters
the government responded by announcing
tough new restrictions on tuesday
closing hair salons and banning public
gatherings of more than two people
at this moment we still feel that this
is the best strategy for hong kong using
all our capacity and our means to ensure
that we could
achieve the dynamic zero target
but the announcement of new restrictions
and disruptions to imports have caused
food prices to skyrocket
as fears of a shortage grow residents
are feeling the pressure
some have begun to question whether the
city's zero-covered policy is worth the
damage that it's causing
now like all the restaurants are closed
and everywhere is the clothes and the
economics already getting back intact
so
um
i guess living with the covet would be
the best solution and the easiest way
i think definitely
it's going to follow mainland right
because it doesn't have any other
options
so if mainland wants hong kong to
continue to lock down then hong kong has
to lock down
for now there is little that hong kong's
7.5 million residents can do but wait
and hope that case numbers begin to fall
as soon as possible
for more let's bring in our
correspondent phoebe kong in hong kong
phoebe what's the latest on these tough
anti-covert restrictions
well hong kong now is suffering from the
most fair outbreak since the pandemic
began in 2020 is the fifth wave of
infection in the city um that like um
over
over a thousand cases were reported
yesterday and another 980 cases are
reported today hitting the record high
so um
there are mass testing being conducted
across hong kong as i'm standing here
next to one of the testing stations we
can see long lines um queuing up to wait
for testing people have to wait for
hours up to six hours or to conduct a
compulsory testings if the residential
areas were a detected virus or infection
so starting from today the government is
imposing the most draconian measures
since the outbreak began and that
public gathering of more than two people
and a private gathering of over two
families are banned and also a series of
stringent measures that um hair salons
and religious venues like churches and
temples have to be shut
the government is also laying out a
vaccine passed in two weeks
requiring all citizens and people in
hong kong but have to show the proof of
fascination uh to enter many private
venues and public facilities so the
government is always really trying every
mean to eliminate the virus from the
community
how are hong kong's hospitals and
critical infrastructure faring in this
current wave of infections phoebe
um well seriously that is a pressing
problem facing the hong kong government
um that according to the authorities um
the occupancy rate of of the isolating
isolation bet at public hospitals is
reaching 90 percent and emergency wards
are also um getting overwhelmed so um
public hospitals is really running out
of resources to accommodate new patients
oh and we're talking about over a
thousand patients um getting infected
every single day and so the government
is now trying to transfer some patient
of mild or even no symptom to some
makeshift isolation facilities in a bid
to ease the burden on public hospitals
and also eyeing on hotels to accommodate
new patients some experts even suggest
on the so-called reverse isolation
strategies helping to accommodate the
new infections
now critics say that china's zero covert
policy which now applies to hong kong is
doing more harm than good what's your
impression there
oh well there have been debates on
whether hong kong should stick with the
so-called dynamic zero infection policy
adopted by mainland china or not some
experts and economists suggesting that
such policy is not sustainable
especially when hong kong has already
paid a huge price to contain the virus
for two years
that flights are down
by 90 percent many shops have have been
shut and closed down and some financial
rating institution even
lowered hong kong's gdp growth forecast
this year already so um such policy may
compromise hong kong's um position as an
international aviation and financial hub
but on the other hand hong kong's chief
executive caroline still insists on um
uh uh
like i'm sticking with the uh zero code
policy she thinks this is still the best
option for hong kong because more than
half of the elderly haven't been
vaccinated so that's why um it's not
suitable for hong kong to live with the
virus as the rest of the world is doing
so
phoebe thank you phoebe kong there in
hong kong